ce mois d'octobre a été marqué par un
nouveau surgissement de la violence au
Proche Orient une violence aveugle d'une
brutalité sans
précédent face à cette
situation des inquiétudes et des
interrogations naissent légitimement
dans notre
pays dans ce contexte il me paraissait
important utile et
nécessaire de pouvoir tenir ce débat sur
la situation au Proche Orient
un débat dont je sais qu'il était
souhaité par la plupart d'entre
vous je ne peux pas m'exprimer devant
vous sans revenir sur les faits le 7
octobre dernier une attaque terroriste
barbare a été menée par le Hamas et le
Djihad islamique contre l'État
d'Israël des centaines de civils ont été
massacrés des crimes abject ont été
commis chaque jour a révélé son lot
d'atrocité
le meurtre sauvage de jeunes lors d'un
festival dans le
désert les horreurs perpétrées dans des
kibutes comme à Berry faraza ou
REIM des femmes des hommes des personnes
âgées des enfants enlevé ou brutalement
assassiné au total près de 1400
personnes ont été tuées dans les
attaques terroristes de ce mois
d'octobre et même si deux otages
américaines ont été libérés plus de 200
personnes sont encore
retenues parmi les victimes 30 de nos
compatriotes ont été tués et se sont
encore portés
disparus cette attaque n'était en rien
comparable aux épisodes de violence
comme il y en a malheureusement eu
d'autres dans l'histoire de cette région
ce déchaînement de barbarie commandité
et mis en œuvre par le Hamas montre un
changement de nature et
d'échelle il s'agissait d'une action
complex et prémédité qui visait à
atteindre Israël et sa population en son
cœur avant de poursuivre mon propos je
tenais à rappeler ce bilan tout comme le
président de la République a déjà eu
l'occasion de le faire et tout comme je
l'ai déjà fait devant cette assemblée je
tenais à dire une nouvelle fois ma
solidarité envers le peuple israélien
dans cette
épreuve
je veux avoir une pensée particulière
pour nos ressortissants en particulier
pour les victimes françaises et les
disparus pour leurs proches leurs
familles nous sommes à leur côté
mesdames et messieurs les députés
minimiser justifier voir absoudre le
terrorisme c'est accepter qu'il frappe à
nouveau demain en Isra
en France ou partout ailleurs nous ne
devons faire preuve d'aucune ambiguité
face à de tels
crimes le président de la République l'a
affirmé avec force Israël a le droit à
la sécurité Israël a le droit de se
défendre dans le respect du droit
international et ceux qui confondent le
droit des Palestiniens à disposer d'un
état et la justification du terrorisme
commettre une faute que et
[Applaudissements]
stratégique ils ne servent en rien la
cause palestinienne et soyons très clair
les Palestiniens ne sont pas le Hamas le
Hamas n'est pas le peuple
[Applaudissements]
palestinien l'Autorité palestinienne est
notre interlocuteur légitime qui se bat
depuis des années pour la paix en
agissant comme il l'a fait le Hamas a
exposé délibérément de manière
criminelle et cynique toute la
population de Gaza il utilise les
populations civiles comme boucliers
humain en agissant de la sorte le Hamas
met en péril les espoirs de paix dont
les Palestiniens ont tant
besoin si je souhaite commencer par
rappeler le bilan tragique des attaques
terroristes de ce mois d'octobre si je
m'apprête à évoquer les milliers de
victimes civiles de Gaza et la situation
humanitaire épouvantable dans la zone
c'est parce que nous ne devons pas
perdre de vue l'ampleur et la gravité de
la crise qui se joue il y a des morts il
y a des familles brisées c'est une
tragédie et les tragédies se prêtent mal
aux postures ou aux indignations à
géométrie
variable
il n'y a pas de victime qu'il
conviendrait de pleurer moins que
d'autres il n'y a pas de vie qui valent
moins que
[Musique]
d'autres la situation la tragédie et le
nombre catastrophique de victim font
monter dans le monde entier une profonde
indignation dans chacune de nos
interventions nous aurons l'occasion de
faire entendre nos sensibilités
politiques et nos différences c'est sain
c'est souhaitable c'est le principe même
du débat
démocratique mais face à la gravité de
la situation il nous faut agir en
responsabilité ces moments nous
appellent collectivement à la hauteur et
à la mesure ne le perdons pas de
vue en prononçant ces mots en prononçant
ces
[Musique]
mots en prononçant ces mots je v plîers
collègues ministre en prononçant ces
mots je voulais affirmer ici mon soutien
et celui de mon gouvernement à la
présidente de l'Assemblée
[Applaudissements]
nationale après les accusations ignobles
proféré à son
[Musique]
encontre mesdames et messieurs les
députés depuis le 7 octobre le président
de la République a été en contact très
étroit avec les autorités
israéliennes avec un message clair
Israël a évidemment le droit de se
défendre face au terrorisme les civils
doivent être épargné la réponse
militaire doit se faire dans le respect
du droit international notamment droit
international humanitaire les
populations ne doivent pas payer pour
les crimes des
terroristes notre pays ne connaît que
trop
bien notre pays ne connaît que trop bien
le lourd tribut des attentats et nous
devons l'affirmer avec force dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme il ne s'agit
jamais de se renier si le terrorisme
doit être combattu la réponse des
démocraties doit être juste même dans
les combats les plus durs les plus âpres
nous ne devons jamais perdre de vue ce
qui fait n de nous des démocraties nos
valeurs le respect de l'État de droit
comme le droit international
humanitaire notre amitié et notre
solidarité avec le peuple israélien nous
oblige à formuler cet appel Israël ne
doit pas tomber dans le piège du
Hamas plusieurs milliers de Palestiniens
sont morts à Gaza dont de nombreux
enfants les 2 millions d'habitants de
Gaza sont dans une situation d'une
extrême gravité ces milliers de vies
fauchés nous ne les oublions pas je ne
les oublie pas mesdames et messieurs les
députés dans ce contexte le gouvernement
est mobilisé sur plusieurs fronts et
nous avons pris ces derniers jours les
mesures urgentes et immédiates qui
s'imposaient je pense que le débat
pourrait appeler à la dignité monsieur
le député
[Applaudissements]
tout d'abord nous agissons depuis la
première heure pour la sécurité de nos
ressortissants une cellule a
immédiatement été activé au Centre de
Crise du ministère des Affaires
étrangères les services du qu d'orsé
notre ambassade et notre consulat
général à TelAviv notre consulat général
à Jérusalem trava jour et nuit pour
assurer un soutien aux familles de nos
compatriotes porter disparu ou tuer dans
les attaques nos ambassades dans la
région notamment à Beyrouth Aman et au
Ker sont totalement
mobilisé bien sûr nous accordons une
attention particulière aux familles des
disparus le président de la République
s'est entretenu vendredi avec elle comme
la ministre des Affaires étrangèr
Catherine Colona avait eu l'occasion de
le faire à tel avive il y a une semaine
nous sommes en permanent avec ses
familles pour répondre à leurs
inquiétudes s'agissant des otages je
veux l'affirmer solennellement nous
mettons tout en œuvre pour obtenir leur
libération immédiate et sans
conditions vous comprendrez que je ne
puisse pas en dire plus nous sommes par
ailleurs en lien avec la Communauté
française sur place pour lui apporter le
soutien nécessaire en 2 semaines la
France a permis à 3600 de nos
compatriotes de rejoindre le territoire
national depuis Israël avec
l'affritement de moyens civils et le
soutien de nos armées je n'oublie pas
les dizaines de Français bloqués à Gaza
dans des conditions extrêmement
précaires la ministre des Affaires
étrangères a pu s'entretenir par
téléphone avec beaucoup d'entre eux lors
de son déplacement dans la région nous
poursuivons nos efforts pour qu'il
puisse quitter la
zone permettez-moi de rendre une
nouvelle fois hommage aux diplomates aux
militaires au fond
français engagé sans compter dans cette
situation éprouvante
[Applaudissements]
ensuite la France est mobilisée pour
venir en aide aux populations de Gaza à
Gaza nous devons regarder en face
l'ampleur de la catastrophe humanitaire
en cours l'accès au services essentiel
est quasiment
interrompu l'eau la nourriture le FU
manque je veux être extrêmement clair
personne ne peut rester insensible face
à ce drame
humanitaire derrière le vertigge des
bilans macabres il y a des femmes et des
hommes il y a des familles il n'y a pas
de nationalité d'origine ou de religion
qui vaille pour mesurer la gravité des
événements quand des civils meurent
chaque vie civile perdue est un échec
pour la communauté
internationale les populations
palestiniennes ne peuvent être
abandonnées à leur propre sort notre
solidarité avec elle ne saurait être
mise en
doute c'est pourquoi nous demandons une
trêve humanitaire qui permette un accès
sûr et immédiat pour l'acheminement de
l'eau de nourriture de fioule et d'aide
humanitaire et médical à
Gaza cet accès doit se faire sous les
gites des Nations Unies et la sécurité
des personnels human
être
garanti même si deux convois ont pu
franchir la porte de
Rafa même si deux convois ont pu
franchir la porte de Rafa entre l'Égypte
et la bande de Gaza tout reste à faire
pour qu'une aide à la hauteur de la
situation puisse être fourni aux
populations civiles l'ouverture au point
de passage de Rafa est encore très
limité nous appelons à ce que la porte
de Rafa soit ouverte pour permettre de
nouveaux passages comme l'a souligné la
ministre Catherine Colona au CA ce
weekend la distribution d'aide exige une
trêve humanitaire qui pourra mener à un
cesser le feu nous demandons cette trêve
au plus vite c'est un point important et
je le répète face aux contevérités
diffusé notamment par la propagande
russe au Conseil de sécurité la France a
soutenu le projet de résolution présenté
par le Brésil dans cet objectif la
ministre des Affaires étrangères par ce
soir à New York précisément pour faire
avancer les négociations au Conseil de
sécurité nous appelons à mettre fin le
plus vite possible à cette période de
violence la la France a toujours soutenu
les populations civiles palestiniennes
elle a ainsi fourni près de 100 millions
d'euros d'aide pour les Palestiniens en
2022 cette aide est concentrée sur des
secteurs vitaux l'eau la santé
l'éducation
l'agriculture face à la situation
actuelle comme l'a annoncé le président
de la République nous avons décidé d'une
aide supplémentaire de 10 millions
d'euros et nous enverrons prochainement
un avion de fret humanitaire pour
soutenir la population de Gaza en outre
l'Union européenne est le premier
fournisseur d'aide humanitaire à la
Palestine et au sein de l'Union la
France en est l'un des premiers
contributeurs face à l'urgence l'Union
européenne a répondu présent le montant
de son aide humanitaire à Gaza a été
triplé et de vol ont permis d'acheminer
plus de 50 tonnes d'aide à la frontière
le Conseil européen de cette fin de
semaine sera l'occasion de revenir sur
le sujet et de faire le point sur le
soutien que l'Europe peut
apporter puisque j'évoque l'aide que
nous apportons à la population
palestinienne de Gaza je voudrais en
profiter pour revenir sur certaines
questions soulevées ces derniers jours
il est légitime de s'interroger et de
veiller à ce que notre aide humanitaire
ne puisse pas tomber entre de mauvaises
mains c'est important pour autant pour
autant gardons-nous de jugements attifs
et définitifs qui ne se fonde que sur
une vision biaisée des faits les
procédures mises en place pour éviter
tout détournement de notre aide par le
Hamas ou le Djihad islamique sont
stricts et scrupuleusement respectés
d'abord notre aide bilatérale comme pour
tous nos partenaires est fourni avec
l'accord de la communauté internationale
dont Israël selon des procédure agréé
ensuite notre aide est mise en œuvre par
des agences de l'ONU et porte sur des
projets concrets comme je l'ai évoqué
enfin les aides sont contrôlées par
l'administration israélienne elle-même
c'est le cas pour nous comme pour nos
partenaire mesdames et messieurs les
députés le troisième pilier de l'action
de la France c'est la mobilisation pour
éviter un embrasement
régional depuis le 7 7 octobre le
président de République la ministre des
Affaires étrangères et le ministre des
armées ont multiplié les échanges avec
leurs homologues ces échanges se
poursuivent la ministre Catherine Colona
s'est rendue en Israël à Jérusalem Est
au Liban en Égypte elle est également
retournée au caer samedi dernier pour y
participer à la conférence de paix et le
président de la République sera demain
dans la région pour faire valoir nos
propositions et éviter l'escalade
plus largement la France se mobilise
pour un règlement durable du conflit
avec la mise en place d'un processus
politique pour une solution à deux états
car nous le savons la lutte contre le
terrorisme ne peut remplacer la
recherche de la paix il n'y aura pas de
paix durable pour Israël et les pays de
la région sans une perspective politique
pour les
Palestiniens
la solution est claire des garanties
indispensables pour la sécurité d'Israël
et un état pour les Palestiniens c'est
la ligne que la France défend avec
constance et qu'elle continuera à
porter la sécurité durable de l'État
d'Israël la lutte résolue pour
l'éradication du terrorisme dans la
région et le respect des aspirations
légitimes de chacun forment un ensemble
indissociable les États de la région ont
à ce titre une responsabilité
particulière la dynamique de
normalisation des relations entre Israël
et plusieurs États de la région est
souhaitable elle doit s'accompagner d'un
processus politique pour répondre aux
aspirations légitimes des Palestiniens
et des
Israéliens notre responsabilité est
grande et nous l'assumons la France est
capable de parler à tout le monde elle
est l'ami d'Israël l'ami des
Palestiniens elle est l'ami des pays
arabes dans la région c'est une position
indépendante que nous avons toujours
assumé une position qui nous donne un
rôle pivot pour aider à tracer le chemin
de la paix mesdames et messieurs les
députés la situation au Proche Orient
est
complexe difficile elle conduit à des
drames épouvantables comme nous avons
encore pu le mesurer ces derniers jours
elle a des conséquences lourdes sur la
sécurité internationale
elle trouve un écho particulier dans
chaque pays dans ce contexte la France a
une voix singulière une voix issue d'une
longue histoire qui nous confère une
responsabilité une voix qui ne méconnaît
aucune des souffrances et défend
toujours l'exigence de justice et le
respect du droit
humanitaire cette voix la France
continuera inable
nous n'avons pas le droit de renoncer la
seule solution c'est la paix je vous
remercie merci
[Musique]
beaucoup merci beaucoup madame la
Première
ministre